good morning everybody happy
monday may the 4th be with you and all
that good stuff so it's may 4th
um let's see the sun is shining here in
southern california not a cloud in the
sky so
shaping up to be a great monday uh we've
got uh my father dr
wallock with us again today today to
talk about a couple different things one
of you know
i get a lot of questions about uh the 10
bad foods and and what constitutes good
foods and
all of that and you know my father's
been lecturing about this for
probably as far back as i can remember
so more than 50 years and uh so he is
clearly an expert on the good foods and
bad foods but you know we've all
probably uh seen and read the things uh
for instance uh let food be thy medicine
and
and and those sorts of things and one of
the things i've always been taught
and believed to be very true is that
dietary supplements are really an
extension of foods
and so a lot of a lot of things that
that do us good come from some food
source
and certainly dietary supplements and
nutrients are those and
the the definition of a nutrient is
a beneficial um thing that the
the body can use that
obviously we get from typically our food
certainly our bodies were designed
to get our nutrients from foods and so
we're going to talk about
that because it's a hot topic and
continues to be a hot topic
as to what is a good food what is a bad
food and certainly what are the 10 bad
foods
that dr wallach talks about all the time
and so we're going to start there but
i've got my be the change coffee this
morning which
uh among my favorites of course in terms
of youngevity products and certainly in
terms of coffee
so good morning dr wallach and dad well
good morning sir
okay mister let's jump into it let's
jump into
um uh what are the what are the bad
foods let's start there
okay well let me give an example first
um let's go back a hundred years ago
during the spanish flu
20 million 20
million people from india died of the
flu
100 million people actually i think was
103 million
people actually contracted the the
spanish flu
20 million died okay
and then you look at india today
30 thousand have contracted the covet
virus and one thousand
have died huge difference
so what's the difference well prior to
uh 1918 when when the
spanish flu hit us um the
people from india were doing all the bad
stuff eating the bad foods
and today they're not eating the bad
foods so you go from
what is it to 20 million
dead 100 years ago and converting to the
good foods now there's only a thousand
dead
uh there's a big difference when you
look at the pre-existing conditions
um that afflict people who have coveted
and are more likely to die when they
have these pre-existing conditions
they're all nutritional deficiency
diseases one of which is not
the most primary one is not even listed
it should be number one which is
osteoporosis and i spent a lot of time
over the last couple of weeks
redoing autopsies were published
online and i asked the same question
what was the cause of death he'd say oh
we had 400 covet deaths
okay what was the cause of death uh uh
well i had to go look all that up
because nobody was saying what the cause
of death was in these covids
okay it turns out that capillary
hemorrhage
is uh high okay
as a cause of death uh also
um people um
get these infections because they have
low platelets
they bleed because they have low
platelets and they get the infections
because they don't have any white blood
cells
our immune system includes white blood
cells platelets
antibodies all of which are formed in
the bone marrow what's happening is
people have a high rate of of fibrous
dysplasia of the bone marrow which means
that the bone marrow cavity which makes
white blood cells and platelets and
red blood cells and antibodies gets
filled up
with scar tissue and all those cells are
gone and you can't make what they're
supposed to make
that's why kids when they get the covet
virus
at 3 5 8 10 12 15 years of age they get
a minor
cold symptoms maybe even a half a degree
fever that's it
now once you're 60 years old and older
you
you've acquired all these pre-existing
conditions because you've been eating
bad foods
all these years old can do the bad
things all these years and so suddenly
now
um the death rate is extremely high it's
like
98 percent of the people who die have
these pre-existing conditions which are
all these nutritional deficiencies
and they're dying of hemorrhaging
they're dying of
of um secondary infections and not
really the covet virus
okay so let's go back to india 100 years
ago
what were they eating well wheat came
from
india iran and iraq thousands and you
know eight ten
thousand years ago and so people in
india they were eating wheat
their intestines were all damaged with
celiac disease they couldn't absorb
nutrients and so
when the h1n1 came through their aka
spanish flu
it wiped out more people than most
countries have people
in india well today the biggest rice
eaters
in the world are from india okay so now
they're eating rice which has no gluten
in it
okay so they don't get the problems that
you get with gluten which are celiac
disease so you can't absorb nutrients
even if they're in your food or even if
you supplement
and so now only a thousand have died
compared to 20 million
100 years earlier so that's the
difference
and so it's very very important to avoid
the bad foods and anybody who says i can
just eat well and get most of what you
need that's not true
any doctor who said that should be put
in jail for
our reckless endangerment there's a few
places on earth we can get some minerals
of two-thirds of the 90 essential
nutrients
or minerals um there's a book
written about it called lusterize there
was a movie made about 1933
because those people lived to be 250 to
300 years of age they had the
highest rate of long-sleeved people on
earth in this one place
because the glaciers the guildtar
glacier was grinding up all the minerals
and the rocks and the canyons and things
and
they were using those waters for cooking
and irrigating and drinking and so forth
and getting the minerals
well essential minerals occur
in veins like chocolate and chocolate
ice cream that occur in veins like gold
and silver and coal
they don't occur in a uniform black
around the crust of the earth
[Music]
over a hundred years ago uh before we
had electricity
our source of nutritional minerals
uniformly around the world was wood
ashes they would people take wood ashes
from their wood stoves or fireplaces and
throw the wood
ashes in the gardens and they didn't
know why the garden grew better but they
knew the gardens grew better with wood
ashes that's because wood ashes are like
90 minerals i heard let me jump in at
that because i heard something this
morning
that's unique about may 4th that ties
into that
and i found it really interesting
because it ties into exactly what you're
talking about
uh in england uh where the uh
chimney suite came from they used to use
children because the
chimneys were very narrow and so
they would the chimney sweeps would cut
these sweets
chimney sweets yeah they would they
would collect the wood ash
and the people that would clean all the
the chimneys
and the fireplaces would take all that
wood ash and sell it to the farmers
so i found that interesting and it's
tied to may 4th because it was a day off
for the
chimney sweeps apparently but anyway
okay so that kind of sets the stage um
all vertebrates including human beings
that's why my thesis is in the
smithsonian institute national treasure
we've found that uh all vertebrates
including human beings require these
mineral nutrients sixty two thirds of
the ninety
and they prevent diseases that doctors
yet today say are genetic or autoimmune
and so forth are really just simple
nutritional deficiency diseases
things like lupus and fibromyalgia and
uh that kind of stuff
are really just nutritional deficiencies
and they make up some of the
the pre-existing conditions that people
have that are going to die if they get
the coven
okay because their bone marrow cavities
are filled up with scar tissue they
can't make white blood cells
they can't make antibodies to defend
themselves they can't make platelets
prevent from bleeding to death
that was a big cause of death during the
spanish flu
when you look up the cause of death from
spanish flu is hemorrhage
people they weren't dying of pneumonia
um even though they called the spanish
flu they were dying from hemorrhage they
were bleeding through their nose they
were throwing up blood they were pooping
blood they were pee and blood their
blood was coming out of their ears their
eyes
because they couldn't make platelets
because they were eating wheat for ten
thousand years and nobody
had any um bone marrow
cells that actually
helped the bone marrow make platelets
and red blood cells and so forth
so this is where our problem is
okay it's not how much heat it's what
you eat
and what you supplement with because
plants only require three elements from
the soil
to make good seeds for the next
generation we need 60. so most people
are 57
sharp anybody who says ah
just eat well you're going to get most
what you need that would be
the same as saying to you if you had a
lamborghini
lamborghinis have twelve
i don't know but let's see that
mcdonald's uh
uh bun doesn't have 90 essential
nutrients and i remember you telling the
story about wonder bread and why it's
called wonder because you wonder what's
in it
yeah and so anyway you go to your
mechanic say okay i've got a 12-cylinder
race car here this thing is beautiful i
want to take it up to india and run
around the track with it
do i need to put special oil in there
now don't waste your money in special
oil
just take dirt from texas and dirt from
oklahoma and put in the car there's
bound to be some oil in there
when the same person wouldn't do that to
their car yet when a medical doctor says
oh just eat well you get everything you
need everybody does that
that's why we have a problem so you do
have to supplement
to guarantee they're going to give your
body the 90 essential nutrients your
bone marrow is doing what it's supposed
to do
make platelets to prevent bleeding to
death
make white blood cells to attack viruses
make antibodies to kill and attack
viruses to make red blood cells to carry
oxygen
and so forth that is amazing to me still
to this day that
you know people will listen to their
medical doctor
about dietary and nutritional advice and
information
and yet medical doctors have no
requirement
um to study diet and nutrition that's
right
it's usually a blind spot for them
yeah so that's why they would say oh
geez well you're getting everything you
need that's set out of ignorance and of
course
um as a result that one sentence kills
more people
than covid right because by far
yeah this is why we have all these
pre-existing conditions so anyway the
bad foods
when you look at now let's look at italy
versus germany
now in current times the italians have
the highest rate
of death from the covet 19. it's um
10 ours is 3 percent
the germans have 0.5 percent
their necks are neighbors okay so what's
the difference
well the italians have been eating for
over 10 000 years
gluten wheat barley around oats they
still eat gluten
wheat brown around oats spaghetti pasta
pizza crust
mustard choli all that kind of stuff
spaghetti and noodles and
so there's there's no gluten in coleslaw
it may depends on what the dressing's
made out of okay
but the germans eat potatoes the germans
were famous for
german potato salad and baked potatoes
and so forth so the germans primarily
get their carbohydrates from potatoes
corn and rice i've got that from 10
different sources okay
where the italians get most of their
carbohydrates from wheat
barley rye and oats okay and so as a
result
for 10 000 years the italians get hit
hard every time
something like this comes through
because they don't have the white blood
cells to defend themselves they don't
have anybody to
defend themselves they don't have
platelets to fend themselves um
and so and they bleed to death okay
now it's because they're eating the bad
foods okay so let's go over the bad food
this is how important it is
to avoid the bad foods um you don't want
to be dipping
breadsticks in olive oil it's for our
our
bread or toast or something like that
waffles
pancakes um the breakfast of champions
wheaties um things like uh oatmeal
and then you have of course um a cream
of wheat you're giving little babies
all right um all of these things have
gluten in them no
no no no no can't have it now you
brought up pancakes
so i have to i have to jump in uh for a
moment uh
let's see with like youngevity go foods
pancake mix it's gluten free
tested gluten-free so it's not that the
pancakes are bad it's the gluten
contained in some pancakes is bad well
when you're in italy you're going to
have pancakes that are made from wheat
if you're
in a youngevity family you're going to
be eating pancakes that are made from
gluten-free flour
but my point i guess is that it's it's
um
it's what's contained in pancakes
traditionally
is what's bad it's the gluten from the
wheat yeah but just
you know again go back to the spanish
flu 100 years ago the
the people in india had been eating
wheat for
12 15 000 years and when it came through
it killed
20 million of them in fact well in the
roman army you said it
at one time i remember you telling uh
talking about the roman army was
actually brought down
uh not by enemies but by um malaria
essentially uh a pandemic right so
spaghetti yeah
yeah and so yeah it's one of those
things where
you know if you can get spaghetti that's
made from
buckwheat okay or rice
you're fine but if you if you don't know
what that spaghetti is made out of don't
eat it because it's probably wheat
because if it's
if they go into the trouble to make it
out of rice they're going to has say
gluten-free
rice based and whatever and so you have
to look at the ingredients and i used to
think that asian foods were you know all
rice
and i used to eat um sushi
three days a week for lunch or dinner i
oh my gosh and what a wonderful thing is
made from
seaweed and rice and avocados and salmon
and then one day i got a rash and so i
said this this feels like gluten here
and so i went and asked the company i
said do you guys make your own sushi
well we used to but the guy who was
famous for it in our
company you know he retired and nobody
else could make it like him so he
started just buying it
you know from a commercial producer do
you have one of those boxes because
milan and i would eat there three days a
week
yeah so bring me the box on the back
there's three sources of wheat flour
in the sushi commercially prepared sushi
and the wheat flour is used to hold the
rice granules in the sushi roll so they
wouldn't fall out when they were being
served
okay so they had added the wheat flour
to sushi with his which had been
gluten-free for thousands and thousands
of years okay
but because they didn't have an artist
to make it properly they threw the wheat
in to hold it together
so you really have to read labels
because you are not what you eat you are
what you
absorb okay very important and of course
there's bagels and
and uh cookies and donuts and
all this stuff and so you really have to
read labels and make sure that they're
all
made from things that don't have any
even things like
malted milk that sounds harmless malted
milk or kind of like a super milkshake
well what was what was the malted piece
well the malted piece was malted rye
grain okay to thicken the malted milk
and give it more oomph well it gave more
of all right but they got gluten
and so you really want to watch it
and as a result when you don't absorb
these things
these nutrients because your intestines
are damaged from the gluten you get
celiac disease which we knew 8 000 years
ago
a greek physician noted that all the
people who
died from celiac disease which was a big
big problem eight ten
twelve thousand years ago intestinal
problems
um he said every one of them eat sweet
he said that eight thousand years ago
then 2250 years ago 250 bc
a roman physician said everybody with
severe
celiac disease or the most common side
effect is
osteoporosis well when you get
osteoporosis guess what your bone marrow
cavity
is clogged up with scar tissue okay you
get um
this uh conversion
of your cells in your bone marrow that
make white blood cells and red blood
cells
and antibodies and and platelets okay
um it turns into
a dysplasia it's called okay fibrous
dysplasia it all turns in just like
tendon-like materials which can't make
anything
and so that's our problem that's why
that should be the number one
thing in the pre-existing conditions for
people who die
from the covet virus these are the
these are the wheat eaters and we didn't
quite get to that i think i think maybe
we did
that the italians eat wheat wheat wheat
wheat and their death rate is 10
from cova and their next our neighbors
the germans their
carbohydrates come from potatoes and and
corn and rice and they have the lowest
rate of death from the coconut zero
point so we've spent a lot of time on
gluten because we're going to run out of
time
by the time we get uh many more of these
bad food clothes
let's get the next one so gluten is the
top of the list that's right
that's the big daddy pinnacle of
the pyramid okay incinerate and then uh
oils are bad okay because they oxidize
and turn into trans
all oils are bad we're not talking about
actually
potentially all oils are bad if you heat
them okay even good oils are bad if you
heat them right then they turn into bad
oils
yeah exactly like fish oil epa dha i
mean these are
part of those they're essential
nutrients
but then you go to a restaurant there's
a bottle of salad dressing sitting on
the table been there
every day for six months right and they
just keep adding to it as it goes away
and at the room temperature and
everything and you put that on your
salad with your croutons i don't think
so
you can stay away from all that okay and
only if you have breadsticks with it
yeah exactly
and so um then of course um
let's see here what else is bad oh so
let's let's hold on so let's let's stay
on oils
so for a second so we're talking
uh primarily vegetable oils are
automatically bad right so
so uh sunflower oil canola oil stuff
like that
yeah here's you eat if you eat
sunflowers which are fresh
okay and you eat the sunflowers there's
oil and naturally those sunflowers
that's okay
but if those sunflowers have been stored
for a year
or two years that's why there's dates on
our products because well then it's
rancid oil potentially right so it's
oxidized oil
and potentially aflatoxin aflatoxin
which you've talked about kills bears so
well it kills everybody why do poor
people
have a higher rate of liver cancer than
rich people once because they get the
thrift
store bread that's contaminated with uh
with aspergillus mold which makes
aflatoxin which creates liver cancer
and i discovered that in bears uh in
1967 when i came back from africa it was
the first thing at marlon perkins he
gave me a list of things
to solve for him he says every species
of bear polar bear black bear
grizzly bear um kodiak bear
sun bear every type of bear in zoos in
the world is dying from liver cancer and
the geneticist says genetics
say no no do you do you have a barn here
or a place where you store bear food
yeah let's go look so i stopped at the i
hadn't even take my jacket off eat
marlon perkins pick me up at the
airport and so um we stopped by the zoo
house and picked up a uv
light a black light and he took me to
this barn it's full of all these old
old um loaves of bread from a thrift
store
well i think we talked about this part
um of
of the marlon perkins story and and your
history
um i think when we talked about selenium
which brings up another point
each month i'm trying to put out a blog
post and so from
our discussion on selenium i took a lot
out of that
plus the the story that um
you know the history that i've lived
around all of that in our health claim
petitions that you filed and young jody
filed
uh along with people like the great dr
gerhard trouser and so forth and so uh
so my may uh first blog post which i
think michelle's gonna share on facebook
today
goes through a lot of that history but i
want to stay on the
the uh 10 good foods 10 bad foods so the
oils
it's the rancidity in general but
there's some bad oils the the vegetable
oils
then they use vegetable oil to replace
butter and turn into margarine and
all that crazy stuff too right no
because they they
actually cause cancer and they cause um
a plaque in the arteries cholesterol is
your best friend cholesterol does not
cause plaque in the arteries cholesterol
does not uh cause heart disease
cholesterol makes up 95 of the weight of
testosterone estrogen if you want ed
guys
you know give up cholesterol take some
statin drugs
have you won't have any good times
anymore won't make any more babies
and then also um if you give up
cholesterol you're going to get
alzheimer's disease alzheimer's disease
is a cholesterol deficiency
so stay away from margins stay away from
oils that are not um properly
which i say processed you have to be
free i recommend
uh people consume eggs right good source
of cholesterol
this morning i'll have three eggs for
lunch and i have three eggs for dinner
tonight
so you should use pam or canola oil to
make those eggs
no no use butter butter okay so but
but you can you can make butter uh into
a bad thing also
yeah if you overheat it so just slightly
so how do you
how do you recommend good better best
eating eggs
okay what i do is i like to put soft
poach them
and then i just put as a couple of
pants of butter right out of the
refrigerator on the eggs and it melts
at the egg temperature you know which is
you know like 60 70 degrees or something
like that
that point and so the butter slowly
melts
and i had a baked sweet potato with
butter on it as well this morning
my head you know this is one of the
things that um uh
you know it's it's it's kind of crazy
but it's i would say this is one of your
biggest
vindications because i remember
you lecturing 30 years ago
40 years ago maybe more to stay away
from margarine
to i mean you go through people's
kitchens and throw it away
and um and and people called you you
know crazy back then and oh you know
you're paid by the
the dairy council or the cattle council
or the
the butter council or something i don't
know and so um
because you you you as vehement as you
talk about
gluten and avoiding gluten today you
talked about avoiding margarine
back then and since but what's changed
is now everybody
with with other than the margarine
salesman probably
virtually everybody uh promotes the
benefits of butter now
and that um that it's not bad for you
that it's good for you that that it's
actually a health
uh enhancing food and so
you know i think it's it's crazy because
uh you know
when when dead doctors don't lie the
audio lecture
went viral before people you know knew
what
it was and we're not talking about
today's virus stuff but
um viral in a good way and so you know
before the internet
that that audio cassette tape uh your
lecture went
you know uh viral around the world in
multiple languages and one of the key
takeaways on that lecture which you had
been giving that lecture
long before it was recorded and
duplicated and handed out
was to avoid margarine and butter's
better
to eat butter and so um uh
so you know from that standpoint i just
point out that
you know again this is one of the uh
probably the biggest vindications
because it was one of the
the craziest points of contention among
your credit
critics back then that you would how
dare you would tell people to stay away
from
from uh margarine and embrace butter
well they're selling margin as a way to
prevent plaque in your arteries and
heart disease
which is a total and you knew it was
wrong in the the reverse all along
that's correct because i'm a pathologist
and you know very few people have done
as many autopsies as many species of
bird rates as i have
as my thesis is in the smithsonian
institute well that's the benefit of
original research actually doing the
research yourself of seeing it not just
believing what you've read
well one of the biggest oil questions i
get save around the world is
what about these aromatherapy oils well
like you keep pushing with therapy
you say well it's bad aromatherapy oils
are not oil
chemically they're called an ester
they're two carbons long
and they're not an oil they don't have
double bonds in them and things like
that so chemically they're not really
classified as an oil they're an ester
and so they're quite safe even
they were classed as an oil thousands of
years ago because they were slippery
like other oils
and so they just put them in the same
piece but chemically they're not an oil
so they're quite safe they don't oxidize
that's why you can put some eucalyptus
oil on your shelf and a thousand years
later it'll still be good it won't
oxidize because
it's not an oil it's an ester so that's
another piece
and then fried foods are very very and
this is why when you look at
louisiana next to to new york state and
california and washington state the next
state
that has the worst rate of covet is
louisiana
and 70 of the people who get coveted
infections and death in louisiana are
black men
okay so why is that a genetic thing no
it's the way they eat
eat everything fried get everything
fried that's very that's the nature
of that community there uh in
louisiana's everything's fried
and the men tend to drink beer when
they're working because it's hot and
humid and sweat and so they drink a lot
of beer which is made from
gluten and then women there well why are
they only 30 percent men of 70 said well
the women
even black women prefer to drink wine
which has no gluten in it compared to
beer
if you're gonna drink beer nothing wrong
with that but drink japanese and chinese
beer made from rice
okay do not fry anything there's two bad
things about frying number one you super
heat
fat okay also super heat
oils and they sprinkle
um things like fried chicken and fried
fish with what
wheat and then they fry it in oil so
you're getting a double hit there from
the wheat gluten and also you're frying
it in oil
and so it's very very bad and this is
why they have 70 percent of the people
in louisiana are black men who get
coveted and who die from covet
it's the eating habits and so that
changes
and everybody gets off all the bad stuff
and they take their 90s of nutrients
they absorb the nutrients there won't be
any more
covid problems if you 70 year old people
will be just like a three-year-old who
gets it'll be
minor cold common cold like symptoms so
with fast food restaurants on
pretty much every corner in you know
throughout the united states selling
fried this fried that
potato french fries fried chicken um
all of those things um uh you know how
to how do we have a
chance you know heart disease is the
leading cause of death in the united
states still
one uh depending on which statistic you
look at 500
000 to 1.5 million americans die each
year from heart disease
and heart related events
um around something like a sudden death
heart attack or stroke and so forth
which all tend to be intra-related i
think but so sudden death heart attacks
particularly in young people even
sentiment death syndrome is caused by
deficiency of a single mineral called
selenium sure
yeah and said that's a little bit
different but then if you're eating all
the bad foods
the the selenium deficiency is going to
be 10 times worse
and so it's one of those things where
they're all inter-kind of intertwined
and but fried foods are extremely
dangerous
okay they taste good they're very
seductive they smell good they taste
good
but they will kill you okay they will
kill your bone marrow
cells not because they attack sometimes
in some cases by heating the oils they
will actually oxidize and kill
your bone marrow cell directly but even
worse when you're getting the gluten
you're not absorbing the nutrients
necessary for your bone marrow to make
white blood cells and red blood cells
and platelets and antibodies
and so you're getting a double hit that
way
sugar's bad okay um
a little bit of sugar makes the medicine
go down
but we're talking about a little bit of
sugar you know we're talking about a
couple of drops of honey
we're not talking about three
tablespoons of sugar
on your oatmeal for breakfast that's a
bad so sugar's an interesting topic
so again going back as far back as you
know
us growing up uh you raising us little
kids
you know we didn't get uh sugary foods
we didn't get uh
soda pop and and things like that
growing up
and uh and our kids don't either so
um in terms of sugar you know there's
there's again
i would say varying degrees of even good
as an alternative
in terms of sweetening something and you
brought up honey for instance honey
contains
natural sugar right and um uh
fruit sugar fructose is often confused
with
high fructose corn syrup which is
something different it's a sugar
but it is a really it's like it's like
not only vegetable oil it's like fried
vegetable oil right so it's it's
oxidized yeah it's oxidized and is
potentially
dangerous then you're talking about a
lot of sugar in
uh these these typically these store
brand
um energy drinks and soft drinks and
soda pops and things like that
it's good so so a little natural sugar
we like to use
in the youngevity products for instance
you'll see fructose on the label
now this is not to be confused with high
fructose corn syrup
and we don't use much you'll always see
low low calories
and so we like fruit sugar and we like
to use as little as possible
but the product also needs to taste as
good as possible without using
artificial
ingredients so a lot of sugar a lot of
natural sugar is bad
even a small amount of things like high
fructose corn syrup
you should avoid well they the sugar
oxidizes and turns into bad
compounds which cause inflammation and
so
sugar fried foods um heated oils
these are the things that cause plaque
in your arteries and if there's anything
nice about plaque in your arteries your
arteries can
themselves heal themselves and the
plaque will go away
plaque has nothing to do with
cholesterol heart disease has nothing to
do with cholesterol it was all a myth so
that the
pharmaceutical companies could sell
their anti-cholesterol drugs
so so when you're talking about plaque
can go away
yes that's an interesting topic so um
are we talking about
you know if you're doing bad things
there's still hope to change
your your um
you know your habits and your diet and
make some lifestyle changes and correct
some of the ills of a bad diet
yeah well the plaque in your arteries
remember your arteries are living tissue
and they can heal themselves they want
to heal themselves they have stem cells
to heal themselves
arteries two-thirds of the thickness of
the walls of arteries is connective
tissue the same stuff your tendons and
ligaments are made out of
okay and so the lining is what gets the
plaque
and it's kind of like when people get
eczema
okay when they get eczema that's our
psoriasis that's a really
thick scratchy yucky skin stuff itchy
and red and
miserable sometimes drippy and it's
caused by deficiency of a single
nutrient
kind of a deficiency of a single
nutrient and it's because people again
eat gluten and eat fried foods and they
eat oils and so forth
and so even if you're supplementing with
that nutrient you can't efficiently
absorb it you wind up with all those
problems
but now you get rid of the gluten and
the fried foods and the oils
and the other bad stuff and you take the
90 cents of nutrients your arteries will
heal themselves and even if they're like
95 blocked with plaque and the doctors
want to put in stents and do bypass
surgeries
and all this kind of stuff well guess
what your artist will heal themselves
say well can i have 30 days or 60 days
well yeah
okay well schedule is 60 days from now
well usually in 30 60 days
your your arteries have been working to
heal themselves
you might go from 95 blockage to say
85 blockage well that's a 10
improvement okay and they say well yeah
we've just you know done an
ultrasound and for some reason you're
only 85
well let me have another month or two
and now it goes to 72 percent
and so then say six months to a year
your orders can heal themselves and all
that plaque go away without the risk of
surgery and stints and bypasses now if
you have 99
blockage you might want to have this
trouble
yeah at that point you may want to have
a stint put in or
or bypass surgery to save yourself but
then you got to do all the right things
so that that 99 the blockage goes away
okay
and okay so we're we're running out of
time here so
um is there something beyond um
uh gluten uh oils
fried foods and sugars uh on on your
list we want to talk about or do we want
to get into hydration
let's get into hydration okay so
hydration why is
why is hydration important well
um circulation is very important right
and blood is
is mostly water okay lymph is fun and
yeah i mean
so you know a huge part probably the
biggest part of the human body is
actually water right
it's water correct and so
you if you have a deficiency of water
you're dehydrated right so hydration is
one of the key
things that make everything work well
you can die pretty quickly
you know from being dehydrated
especially in in heat and so forth can't
keep your body cool from the evaporation
of water off your skin
and you can't circulate nutrition you
can't circulate bad foods to get rid of
bad foods or your urine and bowel
movements and things like that
and so um hydration is
extremely important you know you you
might not survive three days without
water in the desert right
kind of thing and so um
uh those things are all very very
important here
and so and of course um
uh i like our rebound because it has a
hundred nutrients 78 minerals where else
are going to get
an energy drink a soft drink a sports
drink a nutrient replacement drink
that has 78 minerals in it and rebound
was created
um because of your relationship with uh
the all-star theo ratliff right because
i mean you
were helping him overcome some some
personal
um health challenges and he was uh
an all-star player playing for the
atlanta hawks with lenny wilkins and
mike glenn and phil oliver back then and
so
um so you were helping him with his
bone and joint issues and um you know
gatorade has been you know a popular
thing among
athletes for quite a while but you know
i think you quickly realized
that gatorade is really salt water i
mean it doesn't have
much in it but sodium and water okay and
and
a little bit of sugar yeah okay
and so yeah so the thing yes things like
gatorade and red wool they're actually i
would call them energy drinks because
they're mostly sugar
and so uh rebound of course um
theo ratliff he'd lost his contract with
the atlanta hawks
he was in big trouble he had bone bones
rice's knees he had the cartilage pop
off his hip he had fractured his wrist
they said he's too fragile to play pro
ball
we rebuilt him in 90 days with the 90s
nutrients in the rebound
and he gets a 40 million dollar contract
okay and played for 11 more years
and so let's see what's 10 times 40
would you look at that it's one of those
things where
um and we deal with so many professional
athletes
okay um evander holyfield he had a heart
attack
boxer heavyweight champion and uh he
couldn't
um box anymore until we got a hold of
him again
um and we rebuilt him using the 90s
nutrients
and our sports drink rebound and so
forth and guess what you know
now i've talked to um obviously i know
theo pretty well i i
spoken with uh evander hollyfield um uh
don't
home nearly as well as you do but uh um
i do remember getting a legal
threatening letter from one of the major
hydration drink companies no i won't say
which one
but uh because several of the basketball
players were
drinking uh rebound in branded cups that
weren't rebound at the
nba games and nba finals and um
so some of our distributors figured out
what was going on and they were posting
and
and promoting the fact that these nba
players were drinking
rebound instead of something else and so
that company didn't like it
and sent us a kind of a nasty room but
uh
yeah no rebound's a very popular
hydration drink and we have
a lot of great hydration drinks and we
have a lot of great supplements that can
can contribute to hydration like um
like like pollen burst one of our most
popular products it's a nutritional
product
uh but you add it to water obviously and
saxi and act and things like this
but rebound is is really a true uh
uh hydration and re-nutrification drink
for
for things like exercise yeah nutrient
replacement of course
evander holyfield he came back and he
boxed for three more years after
he has a heart attack and he was told
he'd never box again
and it took him you know one year out to
heal himself and everything and get on
our program or diet and supplements and
and everything and he comes back in
boxes for three months he had to
he had to fight and take back his
championship because he gave it up
but they were saying oh you're back now
we're not going to give it back to you
you got a box and take it back if you
want it
okay and so these are the sort of things
we do all the time
and of course if people will use our
thing
one of the things i did was i did 1700
autopsies and kids under the age of 10
years of age in kishan province china
through all the efforts of milan's
family and a lot of connections and
everything there
because keyshawn disease is the same
thing deficiency that kills
people from the sudden heart deaths when
they're an athlete 25 000 athletes in
america
under the age of 20 each year died from
this sudden heart death
is causing a deficiency of a single
nutrient and
so i did 1700 autopsies and through
april 16 2013 federal judge ruled in our
favor we had to put that nutrient in
baby farmers
and we eliminated death we
eliminated again that's a big
claim so we're talking hydration and and
nutrition so all that but we're running
out of time so
um so i'm what i want to do is um and
again point people to that blog post
because it goes through a lot of that
but um what we'll do is we'll do another
one of these and
and see what people want to hear more of
and
and so we'll plan on another one but for
now why don't we go ahead and wrap this
up
and thank you so much for being on again
on doc monday and always uh obviously a
wealth of knowledge and history and
and great information so with that
everybody have a great week
talk to you soon god bless and thank you
very much